zehntausende auf der straße in belarus
gibt es wieder massenproteste gegen
staatschef lukaschenko schwere
waldbrände in kalifornien die feuer
breiten sich weiter aus die behörden
verschärfen ihre warnungen noch zwei
stunden bis zum finale bayern münchen
will gegen paris seinen dritten
champions league titel holen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster ja das große thema bei uns
im sport heute rudi oder ganz klar steht
absolut im fokus gucken amt und damit
willkommen zu unserem
nachrichtenüberblick am sonntag doch
zuerst zur politik und ins östliche
europa nach belehrung swo wieder
zehntausende gegen machthaber
lukaschenko demonstrieren und das obwohl
diese unverhohlen mit gewalt droht die
armee hat er bereits in alarmzustand
versetzt das vermittlungsangebot der
osze der organisation für sicherheit und
zusammenarbeit in europa lehnt
lukaschenko nach wie vor ab für begann
rufen nach freiheit schallen durch die
straßen von minsk trotz der massiven
drohungen des machtapparats fordern sie
in der hauptstadt von belarus eine
zukunft ohne dauer herrscher lukaschenko
ein wunsch der billa russen
verschiedenster generationen vereint
rotation lukaschenko wenn du das land
nicht regieren kannst dann hau ab guck
dir all diese jungen leute an und lasst
sie leben
früher wurden diejenigen die offen die
gewalt angesprochen haben gleich
festgenommen
aber jetzt sprechen so viele dass sie
nicht alle verhaften können so groß rot
zwei wochen sind seit der von
manipulationen bestimmten
präsidentschaftswahl vergangen seit zwei
wochen wird im ganzen land gegen ihn
demonstriert präsident lukaschenko
versetzt gestern das militär in
gefechtsbereitschaft beim besuch seiner
streitkräfte bleibt er bei seiner
behauptung das ausland bedrohe belarus
anschuldigungen dieser art auch von
russlands außenminister lavrov beweise
liefert er keine bei seinem auftritt
heute in der nähe von moskau
einige bilder russische oppositionelle
die im westen leben und von dort aus
versuchen die geschehnisse in belarus zu
beeinflussen wünschen sich sehr dass
blut vergossen wird das eine reaktion
der bilder russischen sicherheitskräfte
provoziert wird in minsk zu beobachten
ist heute etwas anderes die friedliche
kundgebung zu der die bälle russische
opposition aufgerufen hat auf der einen
polizei und militär auf der anderen vor
allem lukaschenkos amtssitz wird stark
bewacht dort landet am abend der
hubschrauber des präsidenten kurz darauf
kursiert dieses video dass lukaschenko
mit gewährt zeigt der plan des
belarussischen präsidenten zur stunde
völlig undurchsichtig nach deutschland
das robert koch institut meldet heute
782 00 corona fälle innerhalb eines
tages gestern waren es fast dreimal so
viele 2034
hintergrund ist dass am wochenende
weniger gesundheitsämter ihre daten
übermitteln
im schnitt der vergangenen woche haben
sich laut johns hopkins universität 1340
menschen täglich angesteckt gestern
waren es 1320 viele deutsche
urlaubsrückkehrer aus kroatien haben die
vergangene nacht im stau verbracht wegen
verschärfter corona kontrollen an der
slowenisch österreichischen grenze am
karawankentunnel mussten die autofahrer
bis zu zwölf stunden warten
das verkehrschaos entstanden nachdem
österreichs regierung vorübergehend
angeordnet hatte die personalien auch
von allen durchreisenden urlaubern zu
erfassen
die grünen rechnen sich gute chancen aus
nach der bundestagswahl im kommenden
jahr teil einer neuen regierung zu
werden
offen ist dabei noch in welcher
konstellation und mit welchem
spitzenpersonal eine mögliche
kanzlerkandidaten stellte sich heute den
fragen im zdf sommerinterview
annalena baerbock kann sich verschiedene
bündnisse in berlin vorstellen
thomas reichert in den meisten umfragen
liegen die grünen an zweiter stelle
wer nach der wahl im nächsten jahr
regiert das könnte entscheidend von
ihnen abhängen
im zdf sommerinterview in frankfurt oder
schließt annalena baerbock nun auch eine
ampelkoalition mit spd und fdp nicht aus
natürlich kann ich mir dreier
konstellation auch vorstellen wir
regieren in etlichen bundesländern in
der fdp in der in dreier konstellation
wir haben seit jahren gesagt wir
schließen keine demokratische
kombination aus also auch nicht
schwarz-grün oder rot-rot-grün eine
dieser kombination wird so hoffen die
grünen
sie nach 15 jahren opposition wieder an
die macht bringen
inhaltlich geht es ihnen dabei vor allem
um ein thema das ist glaube ich die
aufgabe unserer generation
klimaneutralität diese gesellschaft
klimaneutral zu machen eine sozial
ökologische marktwirtschaft zu schaffen
damit wir die größte herausforderung
unserer zeit den klimawandel man sieht
auch hier an wasserständen in den griff
bekommen doch ihre kernklientel etwa bei
freier historiker geht es oft nicht weit
genug für ihn dort sind die grünen
inzwischen zu weich zu pragmatisch dass
wir immer wieder von bewegung
aufgetrieben werden
das halte ich für essenziell in einer
demokratie wäre schlecht und alle sagen
wird ist ja schon ganz gut so weil dann
entsteht kein druck dass sich auch
wirklich was bewegt die grünen wollen
projektionsfläche bleiben für viele
wünsche und vor allem dies endlich an
die macht
das sommerinterview mit der
grünen-vorsitzenden annalena baerbock
sehen sie direkt im anschluss an unsere
nachrichten vizekanzler olaf scholz
hofft auf eine erfolgreiche behandlung
des russischen kremlkritikers alexej
nawalny in deutschland gegenüber der
neuen westfälischen sagte er demokraten
könnten es nicht akzeptieren dass das
leben von oppositionellen in gefahr
gebracht werde
navalny liegt seit gestern in berliner
krankenhaus charité
der 44 jährige war vor vier tagen ins
koma gefallen
seine frau und freunde befürchten dass
er vergiftet wurde und nun einblick in
die usa nach kalifornien wo mehr als
13.000 feuerwehrleute weiter versuchen
die verheerenden waldbrände einzudämmen
der bundesstaat und der westküste zählt
inzwischen fast 600 feuer
insgesamt haben die flammen eine fläche
verwüstet die etwa so groß ist wie
mallorca ein schwieriger kampf für die
helfer ein chancenloser für bewohner und
natur britta jäger
sie kämpfen immer weiter keine zeit für
schlaf immerhin seit samstag bekommen
die einsatzkräfte unterstützung aus
anderen us bundesstaaten
das ist so tragisch aber unsere
einsatzleiter haben uns hart trainiert
also sind wir für sowas angemessen
vorbereitet drei riesige feuer und sich
kleinere mittlerweile haben die flammen
insgesamt etwa 4000 quadratkilometern
zerstört bei san jose wütet der
zweitgrößte brand in der geschichte
kaliforniens viele stehen vor dem nichts
zu beginn der katastrophe haben die
nachbarn wie eine familie zusammen
gehalten jetzt sind alle irgendwo
verstreut
auslöser für die heftigen brände waren
vor allem tausende blitzeinschläge hitze
und trockenheit fachten die flammen
weiter an
wenn sie nicht an den klimawandel
glauben kommen sie nach kalifornien
twitter der gouverneur des staates in
die welt wir leben in verrückten zeiten
vor fünf jahren gab es noch nicht jedes
jahr so heftige feuer
jetzt aber gibt es jedes jahr einen
neuen rekord jedes jahr bis in den
dienstag in ein erwarten die
einsatzkräfte neue blitzeinschläge und
den ausbruch weiterer feuer
es wird also möglicherweise noch
schlimmer kommt zum sport und da gibt es
heute nur eine sorge rudi wer gewinnt
die champions league auf jeden fall ein
deutscher trainer das duell der giganten
bayern münchen gegen paris st germain
ist auch das duell der beiden trainer
hansi flick und thomas tuchel
für beide ist es das spiel des jahres
hansi flick hat das größte taktik rätsel
bereits gelüftet an seinem system des
früh attackieren will auch gegen das
konto starke team von paris festhalten
wir haben sehr attraktiven fußball
gespielt werden gegner hoch gepresst und
es war unsere erfolgsgarantie
letztendlich und wir werden da nicht
groß ändern
kollege thomas tuchel will seine
superstars um nehmer ebenfalls genauso
weitermachen lassen wie bisher
das ist jetzt kein zeitpunkt dinge zu
verändern das ist ein großes finale
zwischen zwei starken mannschaften
da werden wir unsere spieler doch nicht
unnötig verwirren
alle also genau wie immer gewinnen wird
nachher aber nur eine um 20 uhr 15
startet unsere live übertragung im zdf
thomas skulski vor dem pse hotel glaubst
du dass die bayern mit einer anderen
startelf als gegen lyon antreten
nein das glaube ich nicht ich glaube
dass die bayern mit derselbe anfangself
wie gegen lyon starten das glaubt
übrigens auch thomas tuchel die hier vor
30 sekunden gerade rausgeholt ist
fröhlich erwartet von 3 400 psg fans die
sich vor dem hotel zur abfahrt der
mannschaft versammelt haben
thomas tuchel hatte wie wir gestern
gelegenheit das abschlusstraining der
bayern zu sehen oder sagte er er hätte
schon erwartet dass hansi flick manager
war auf rechtsverteidiger position
stellt um die op mich frei zu bekommen
fürs mittelfeld aber nach dem was er
beim training gesehen habe glaube er
dass nicht mehr
ich glaube für die bayern kommt es
darauf an unnötige ballverluste zu
verhindern
und als mannschafts formation weit
weniger chancen zuzulassen als es noch
gegen lyon der fall war
weil die herren die hier immer so in den
einzelnen gruppen rauskommen würden
daraus sicherlich weit mehr machen als
dass leon getan
thomas skulski herzlichen dank für diese
impressionen aus lissabon
noch ein blick zur leichtathletik
diamond league in stockholm da gab es
ein highlight mit einer weltklasse zeit
der freudenschrei eines norwegers nach
seiner lauf demonstration carsten warhol
kommt über 400 meter hürden nach 46 87
sekunden ins ziel
europarekord und die zweitschnellste je
gelaufene zeit in dieser disziplin die
konkurrenz chancenlos der zweimalige
weltmeister festigt damit seine rolle
als top favorit auf olympia-gold
nächstes jahr in tokio und das war's vom
sport gedanke hude bleibt noch das
wetter für morgen von norden bis zur
mitte ist es auch stark bewölkt mit
schauern oder auch kurzen gewittern
im süden dagegen länger sonnig und
trocken 18 bis 24 grad
so viel für den moment schön dass sie
dabei waren marietta slomka informiert
sie dann in der halbzeitpause des
champions league finales und an dieser
stelle um 7 übernimmt ab morgen barbara
hahlweg wir wünschen ihnen einen
spannenden abend im zdf über geben aber
jetzt erst einmal anders sommerinterview